à maurepas il faudra faire un choix
entre l'une des quatre listes en course
pour ce scrutin notamment celle portée
par erwan le gall bonsoir mon sens est
grand car vous êtes donc à la tête de
mort pas autrement c'est une liste
divers droite il s'agit d'ailleurs de
votre première candidature comme tête de
liste pour des élections municipales
là on est hardie -5 vue du premier tour
est ce que votre campagne se poursuivait
ce qu'elle est terminée invaincue elle
se poursuit dans les rallyes dans les
règles législatives évidemment du code
électoral et will se poursuit jusqu'à
vendredi minuit alors précision vous
êtes l'ancien premier adjoint de la
commune où le maire sortant grégory
aguirre astier est également candidat
pourquoi vouloir devenir mère pourquoi
vouloir devenir mère parce que il me
semblait important de saisir cette
opportunité pour plusieurs raisons la
première sur un plan purement politique
depuis quelques années depuis françois
hollande jusqu'à maintenant je vois que
le pouvoir d'achat des françaises et des
français commencent à se déliter
fortement et je pense réellement que sur
maurepas il est important aussi de jouer
un rôle pour être sur un plan économique
sérieux et responsable le maire à ce
rôle il peut favoriser le pouvoir
d'achat le premier de le premier rôle à
avoir ça ne pas augmenter les impôts
première chose et ne pas augmenter tout
ce qui est un point direct tout ce qui
est lié aux charges de comptines tout ce
qui est lié au périscolaire
conservatoire et c'est donc ça c'est
vraiment un engagement important
deuxième chose c'est que comme vous le
savez notre liste divers droite centre
jusqu'à 1 droite plus modéré et il n'y a
pas eu de compromission avec l'aéro même
sommes la seule liste des policiers l om
voilà donc oui je pense que c'est un
enjeu important
pourquoi vouloir être mère je vais vous
répondre
également parce que nous sommes portés
par une équipe qui a la volonté d'agir
pour l'europe à aider leurs patients
mais si on parle de votre liste vous en
disiez de mort on précise que vous êtes
le président du comité bino d'objectifs
france qu'un rassemblement de la société
civile et d'élu de terrain est ce que
liszt et à l'image justement d'objectifs
france est-ce que ça rassemble diverses
personnalités divers talents
alors il vous a pas échappé que nous
avons huit étudiants sur la liste trois
chefs d'entreprise quatre anciens élus
des gens qui viennent de la formation du
social du sanitaire et puis d'autres
d'autres de ses d'autres secteurs pas je
ne souhaite pas rapproché objectif
france avec cette liste parce que nous
avons démarré très tard et il n'y a pas
un engagement politique liée objectif
france mais je dois le signal est oui
qu'il ya eu de coup de téléphone du
président d'objectif france et du
général soubelet pour m'encourager et me
dire que la vision du montage de la
liste était effectivement en écho avec
les valeurs de objectif france leçons
des élections municipales où la majorité
en tous cas l'ancienne majorité à
laquelle vous appartenez vous
apparteniez à part divisée est ce que ce
n'est pas une voie ouverte ça justement
pour l'opposition le fait que la
majorité par diviser pour cette
direction écoutez moi j'ai l'impression
que surtout que allait diviser parce
qu'en face en face de nous de notre
liste moore pas autrement
j'ai trois 3 listes différentes certes
mais qui se rapproche sur de certaines
thématiques la première n'échappa qui a
dû l ère où m et puis grégory grassi cas
de rm donc déjà ils ont un point commun
et puis il se paie la one qui a lui une
ouverture beaucoup plus à gauche que que
nous et là vous avez été tout de même
premier attend de la commune laurent
s'il en est ce que ça vous met
totalement le bilan a été porté j'assume
une partie du bilan d'ailleurs j'en
ferais pas bientôt
bien sûr que je suis à partir du bidon
parce que il doit être partagée
d'ailleurs évidemment j'assume -
certaines choses où nous avons été
phagocyté sur sur des actions en interne
voilà parce qu'il ya la démocratie
interne donc si évidemment je je je le
regrette profondément
mais je crois profondément qu'il y à des
actions à mener au niveau de maurepas et
arrêté un petit peu ces clivages
vraiment nous avons et nous conduisons
une liste responsable
alors justement sur ces projets vous
souhaitez mettre en avant une gestion
saine et est responsable de la mairie
est notamment sur le projet de futur
centre aquatique il faut selon vous re
calibrer leur président juste les choses
le projet mené avec elancourt et doit
voir le jour en 2022 et un contrat
délégation de service public a été signé
je veux le dire haut et fort il y aura
l'ouverture de la piscine lorsque nous
arriverons responsabilités en 2022
très clairement il n'est pas question
d'arrêter ce projet par contre nous
avons un temps donné d'ici 2022 pour
revoir avec le délégataire et la ville
d'elancourt parce que c'est pas une
action que je mènerai ça c'est une
action qu'on a mené avec nos partenaires
pour recalibrer certain nombre de choses
tout simplement pour que nous soyons sur
un niveau de dépenses qui étaient au
haut niveau initial si on veut être en
dessous encore mieux voilà ce qui est
dit actuellement que avant les dépenses
de la piscine était de 1 million 2 ce
qu'annonce le maire sortant c'est un
projet qui est chiffré à 24 3 millions
d'après ce qui a été votée au dernier
conseil si un jour d'accord c'est voter
comme ça on le compare par rapport à ce
qui existait avant un million deux
parties dont deux déjà c'était huit cent
mille euros puisqu'il y avait les
recettes à rentrer pour faire l'équation
et la soustraction d'accord ensuite j'ai
assisté mois aux réunions avec le
délégataire et il était initialement
prévu un million par 1 60% pour meurent
pas 40% pour elle en cours nous sommes
plus du tout on ces montants là ça c'est
à recalibrer ou en fait c'est du bon
sens
faisons des choses modestement
modérément mais qui soit en adéquation
avec les besoins de la commune elancourt
maurepas et autres et puis voyons au
bout de 5 6 ans si ça fonctionne
correctement
nous refaisons unodc si une action une
activité différente plus grands on a
tout simplement si la gestion de bon
père de famille un autre axe puisque le
temps avance dans cet entretien
l'environnement forcément c'est un thème
qui revient souvent dans cette campagne
vous souhaitez vous mettre en place un
bilan carbone à mort passe est publié
chaque année ce bilan terrebonne
il n'y a pas de bilan carbone à maurepas
bon moment oui nous voulons le faire je
trouve que c'est essentiel il n'y a pas
que ça dans les mocratie participative
et le rs dans notre pays et resterons a
mis un certain nombre dax qu'il faut
mettre en place avec aussi toutes les
actions communes à 2 des investissements
et de la gestion au quotidien
voilà le rsc un mot fort c'est
l'entreprise qui déploient les rse donc
si nous l'avons mis et nous l'avons
institué comme ça c'est pas par hasard
c'est que ça nous engage il y aura un
adjoint dédié uniquement à cela le bilan
carbone
oui derrière il faut qu'il y ait des
actions fortes et vous avez évoqué la
démocratie participative là où à
maurepas il ya des budgets participatifs
qui sont déjà proposés vous allez il
faut aller plus loin qui sont limitées à
150 mille euros bon écoute et on a vu
les limites de l'exercice voilà je sens
commentaires par contre ce que nous
proposons c'est sur les investissements
des projets clés qui lie à à mettre en
place sur maurepas et c'est le mot
ropa/ca n'aimeront pas ça qui vont
choisir deux projets au choix là où
l'autre et on avancera chaque année
comme ça ça peut être même trois quatre
cinq six projets parent dans tous les
cas ça sera aux mourants pas énorme
occasion de choisir
ça c'est la vraie démocratie
participative c'est pas du saupoudrage
merci d'être venus en plateau tête de
liste de maurepas autrement et face à
vous pour ce scrutin est le maire
sortant grégory vérifier et les deux
conseillers municipaux d'opposition
ismaïl à vannes et michel chapa